good my man idea I love you at the
Farley mural yeah man breaths young man
named Brady Matthews painted this for me
now is his first one well Brady Matthews
needs to hear the story and then we'll
go jump on more stories yeah was jumping
more stories in just a second David
telling I shared an office it's Saturday
Night Live if you want to make sure
nothing gets done put the two of us in
an office like Paul get a box set of
Otis Redding at Lorne gave him for his
birthday and he cut a hole where the
mouth was and put a cigarette in and lit
it like that was 2 weeks of [ __ ]
laughter like how long does a cigarette
lab one of them go faster we're like
he's actually smoke we weren't well so
far Lee comes in on a rewrite night
there's no reason for Farley to be in
the building he was the most beautiful
man I ever met in my life ever
my grandfather my other grandfather read
my mom's that Maurice Ferguson he was he
was the one man I saw him he was the
most beautiful man ever and Chris right
behind him and Chris wasn't sober to two
years I was there it was had his [ __ ]
together and he was you know in a van
down by the river at Sun yeah and he
comes in he goes what are you guys doing
and me and Dave Attell go we'll give you
$100 to take a [ __ ] out the window oh
yeah but we said at the same time like
creepy twins come play with us Danny
will pay 100 he asked us about what we
were doing and our answer at the same
time he's from Brooklyn I'm from Jersey
he's Jewish
I'm Catholic like I would I will give
you $100
like decadence like we were singing a
song the other two [ __ ] out the window
and he goes give me the money first and
we're like oh [ __ ] patent pockets bro
and including and I'm not exaggerating
making lunch baby four dollars in points
it was exactly a hundred dollars and so
he takes the paper money Chris Farley
puts it in his pocket and then reaches
across my desk which is against the
window the longest way you could go and
[ __ ] the strong [ __ ] man lifts
that [ __ ] tilts the desk and the coins
again a cartoon ding-ding-ding into his
pocket like dignity minute like stacks
of quarter stacks of like ding ding ding
ding ding ding it was amazing
drop the desk open that giant ass window
goes up on the window ledge and rest the
window on the back of his neck facing in
the building oh wow is the 17th floor
yeah he could fall to his death at any
moment at his weight risk
he's very graceful man he was at no risk
of lead he have long legs no he was just
like a football player and he just had
incredible power you seem do cartwheels
and [ __ ] and flips he was great the only
thing in the building was like his nose
his hands around his knees like the snot
bubble coming at him and all the holding
just his head against that window well
yeah he's balancing on the ledge as well
right but it became obvious and they do
tell the story on stage it became
obvious immediately the critter gets a
pop he'd have to [ __ ] at all but he had
the money and he always delivers and the
deals a deal but he always delivers so
you're doing that body Tetris at that
point I'm talking about I love you marry
you you start [ __ ] playing Jenga with
yourself bro cause you gotta find a turd
in your body that's true though just
moving around yeah I mean you're doing
things yeah that's gonna give the
diarrhea with the stomachache you like
move this bubble here so that's when you
stuff house when I need that shitty
piece that comes down makes it right and
come down again yeah the one that [ __ ]
up your whole game that a little hitter
you need that baller
so like the windows rattling from effort
like this he's purple
and he's it's Farley's go like it and is
he saying I'm also to make you guys
laugh at this you can't
he's insatiable that way you can't and
after like a minute which is a long time
when a guy's above the skating rink yeah
like if you ever see a fake one Fig
Newton without the Newton yeah one of
those like that size that shape it was
like square shape oh yeah and it was
thin oh yeah I'll guess consistency felt
like the snow through the window behind
him fell from his ass mmm in the window
onto my [ __ ] desk that's a Detroit
dove right there yeah what he wipes his
ass with his hand there's no paper oh we
don't write
we don't write yeah are you doing
nothing in there but [ __ ] I watch him
smoke I Diamond push-ups and I call
escorts and [ __ ] Foy Lee Webb says
with his hand it goes ah it's touch
doing like a zombie walk then starts
change chasing and quo
because he's going azzam be walk me and
Dave Attell are hauling ass down these
hallways but like in scooby-doo he's
always right [ __ ] behind she's going
his eyes are all the way in the back of
his head so we don't know how we can see
and he went from like haha to like oh no
like terrifying
like I fought a harbor heights Mexican
Mafia gang bangers on PCP and he
wouldn't go down I'm like oh this is
great I thought that like right between
the chin and if I'm with his [ __ ]
middle of his eyebrow to like his bottom
lip just but but and I'm like a minute
in you go this is a horror movie and I'm
not like I'm getting tired and he
bugging near you am i but like somebody
[ __ ] Mitch Mulaney gets out of his
car and beats him up and the whole set
Mitch Mulaney like apparently just
fought in Oakland his whole life it was
amazing rest in peace brother saved my
life so far Lee's chasing us around
there's a hallway going to Lauren's
office that's a single file only more
Michaels yeah Lauren green actually he
took over the show for a while did he
really
no you just mentioned Michael Landon so
jump on that I love Michael Landon I
okay have you told him now well I didn't
get my mom almost met him one time at
the fairgrounds but uh we're gonna get
into this on mine let's start more
stories with this okay because this ties
right into everything I was just saying
about your home okay fascinating he was
the ideal he was the guy oh you got it
even the pajamas that were the whole
body red pajamas you're like see that's
what a man wears
oh he was prince henry he was Prince
Henry Prince Harry Prince Harry he was
our you know he was our yeah yeah yeah
he was
estee lauder he was somebody you know he
was the big deal at L and I had a single
file only and I'm like I am I am 11
months removed from college wrestling so
I'm like and this [ __ ] right
next to me ass and elbows Dave Attell
and he's like oh I'm like neither one of
us are giving it up and I'm on the
bookshelf side and it hits my shoulder
and my shoulder comes out of the socket
goes around me like a grandma taking her
bra off at the table yeah it felt like I
just went around my body and if you're
not sure you've been knocked out it's
like I'm not sure if I napped or not you
did because there's no it like no I
didn't tap like I don't know if I napped
like then you'd set Matt someday yes if
your leg and I just get [ __ ] knock
yes yes you did and I
I'm standing there I'm laying on my back
and Farley in the [ __ ] hand he's like
and I'm like um I go [ __ ] you Farley I
broke my [ __ ] joke am i putting on
like really act and I made myself cry
and he goes are you okay and he stands
up I just got up and I ran out of that
[ __ ] building and I jogged home and I
got under the covers it was like the
most amazingly funny the most impossible
thing the most frightening thing and I
like fooled like a beautiful man into
thinking I was hurt like that hurt me
worse than anything he's like are you
okay like when he stopped being a zombie
it was a heartbreaking I just [ __ ]
wanted to throw myself in front of a cab
but that's but it's almost perfect man I
can imagine at that moment you're under
the covers and you created all of these
all of these things happen and you're
filled with all these feeling you're
filled with excitement
laughter fear chicanery because you guys
created this crazy thing the the vision
tom foolery and rumpus the vision that
somebody got [ __ ] on the vision that you
know hurt and all of that it's like an
annual rate will probably just save like
sleep comfortably
that's an enormous event but it just
shows how many feelings you have to have
sometimes an alcoholic to be filled with
to be able to just oh it was an overload
it was too many feelings right but the
one that got me was that are you okay
yeah that [ __ ] to this day I get if I
think about it long enough I'll [ __ ]
cry like that's a beautiful beautiful
man like there's a reason you mentioned
his name and people know oh my god like
yeah you think you know but you don't
know but I'm glad you know what you know
yeah but he was the most beautiful man I
ever met my life not name Maurice yeah
yeah